I took my son to uh pop pop and gammon's
house that's grandma and grandpa for
those of you that don't know but my dad
wants to be called pop pop and my mom
wants to pick called Gammy um they're
both insane but um I drove him to uh my
to their to Grandma's house and
Grandma's Grandma grandma grandpa's
house and when we went there
um he he was like I'm so excited to see
pup pup and Gammy and melted my heart
and then afterwards dude
um
we ate Chinese food and then he ate a
lot of chicken he wanted chicken so he
ate chicken and then they were like do
you want to give him some dessert and I
said no because I had a [ __ ] idea
dude that I was gonna get ice cream with
the boy now let me tell you something
about getting ice cream with the boy now
was his father's son that day okay A lot
of times Kristen comes with us but you
know she had some stuff to do so it just
went just dad and son dude I had a dad a
father and son day which is crazy to
think that I'm a father still you know
it's crazy to think that I'm a father
even still that has been two two in two
years plus
um but uh I took my son to get some ice
cream and I was in line
getting ice cream and it was uh I was
waiting and he was so excited and I was
like what kind do you want and I said
chocolate and he said yes and I said or
vanilla and he said yes so I'm like okay
I guess it's up to me so I got him
vanilla and I got him in a cone and he
sat there and ate it and I was eating it
with him and I didn't even want ice
cream but I was eating a little bit it
was like the cinnamon Snickerdoodle kind
it was really nice it was salt and straw
just absolutely [ __ ] gorgeous in my
mouth dude I mean dude it [ __ ] was I
put it in my mouth that it was just
dancing around it was so beautiful
dancing around playing nice with the
taste buds but my God it was gorgeous
dude I mean I put that [ __ ]
Snickerdoodle cinnamon style in my mouth
with the spoon and [ __ ] it was
gorgeous dude I met it it [ __ ] might
as well have been [ __ ] Colin Farrell
sex tape because it was [ __ ] gorgeous
God was so gorgeous the Snickerdoodle
cinnamon in your mouth is gorgeous
so I ate it and my son was licking it
and I said why don't you bite it and he
said no dust Yik huh and he would lick
it and dude I was sitting there and I
took some pictures you know I looked
like a dorky dad whatever I was wearing
the [ __ ] full purple life ripped suit
I look like a [ __ ] jackass but that's
just how I I you know that's just how I
[ __ ] that's how I rolled right that
day and I didn't want to change for
nobody
and I brought my son to
um
get ice cream and he was eating it dude
and I was thinking about like how cool
it was to be a kid right like a lot of
the times when you have a kid you think
about like oh you get to rely people say
like oh you get to relive the moments
from your childhood just in a different
way and you get to experience it via
your kid and how amazing that is and
that is amazing but I actually on the
drive home thought about like something
that I don't know I I think I think
about this less than that first thing I
just said but the fact that I
got to have ice cream with my son is
such a it's such a great I'm so lucky
for that I'm so lucky that I was able to
experience taking my loved one to ice
cream
and giving that to him and watching The
Joy on his face that is so beautiful for
me to experience now I usually think you
know because look I'm myself I've been a
selfish guy in my life and this is a
very selfish thought thinking about how
how you know I'm it's not selfish it's
grateful I'll say it's grateful it's not
like I'm like [ __ ] yeah this is awesome
I get to it's not like [ __ ] going and
getting a [ __ ] you know
a BJ or some [ __ ] it's not like going
and getting some [ __ ] Pizza where
everything's just gorgeous in your mouth
you know I was doing it because I'm
grateful to I was thinking
I'm grateful I get to experience this
but anyway what I've what I'm trying to
say is I used I I have lived selfishly
right like in my life before and I'm
still selfish sometimes but I try to
keep that in check and I try to be
grateful and do uh more things for other
people and live like that but my point
is when it comes to my son all that [ __ ]
kind of goes out the window and I just
want him to be happy so I'm mostly
thinking of oh I want him to have ice
cream because I want him to be happy oh
I want him to go to the park because I
want him to be happy but I actually got
to sit in the gratefulness of it in the
oh wow I get to experience this I'm so
lucky that not everybody gets to
experience this look it's a very common
thing taking your son to ice cream but I
think this sitting in and actually
realizing what's happening in your life
and how great of a moment this is
is is is not something that I'm always
thinking of and I got to sit and take
that in in that moment and I don't think
I'm ever going to forget that dude I was
sitting outside I took some pictures and
it was beautiful and it was just licking
the ice cream and then and that's it and
that's it dude it's not even really a
story to tell it's just a [ __ ]
check-in with you guys about how
grateful I am for moments like that you
know
I think we get so uh uh consumed with oh
am I gonna like this is he gonna like
this is she gonna like this are they
gonna like this or am I accepted but I
just the moment was beautiful dude and
I'm so happy I was so happy for that
moment dude
um and that's it and that was a little
bit more dramatic than I thought it
would be but whatever it doesn't matter
life keeps on ripping dude life keeps on
ripping dude you lick that ice cream and
life keeps on
um
it keeps on ripping gorgeous crazy
[Music]
crazy congratulations
[Music]